[Música]
prisión preventiva para Pedro Castillo
la justicia determinó que el
expresidente peruano deberá permanecer
detenido durante 18 meses mientras es
investigado por presunta rebelión y
conspiración además el gobierno decretó
toque de queda en 15 provincias del país
Tenemos reporte desde Lima
la justicia brasileña emitió más de 100
órdenes de búsqueda y captura contra
Seguidores del presidente Jair bolsonaro
por lo que denominó como actos
antidemocráticos que incluyeron bloqueos
de carreteras y que se desataron tras la
victoria de Lula da Silva en las
elecciones ampliamos desde Río de
Janeiro
el gobierno de Honduras y Naciones
Unidas firmaron un memorando para
establecer la comisión internacional
contra la corrupción e impunidad un
organismo independiente que se encargará
según dijeron de investigar las redes de
corrupción público privadas de alto
impacto en el país
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias de
América en France 24 los saluda Andrés
Meza Muñoz empezamos en Perú porque el
juez del supremo ordenó 18 meses de
prisión preventiva para el expresidente
Pedro Castillo el dictamen se da en
medio de las investigaciones en contra
del expandatario por los presuntos
delitos de rebelión y conspiración
previamente hablamos con nuestro
corresponsal en Lima Francisco Zacarías
quien nos contó Cuáles fueron las
causales del magistrado para tomar la
decisión contra Castillo
Buenas noches fueron tres largas horas
de lectura de la resolución el juez Juan
Carlos checkley validó las acusaciones
de la fiscalía contra el expresidente
Pedro Castillo porque afirma que este
cometió los delitos de rebelión
conspiración abuso de autoridad delito
contra la paz pública por eso la corte
peruana le ordenó 18 meses de prisión
preventiva el juez checkley también
señaló que Pedro Castillo luego de leer
su mensaje donde ordena la disolución
del Congreso se dirigió a la embajada de
México y este eso constituye un peligro
de fuga y bloqueo al proceso y también
recordó que hora después precisamente
ese país habló sobre un eventual asilo
político contra el ex mandatario esta
corte le tocó otorgarle mejor suerte al
ex Primer Ministro Aníbal Torres porque
a él solamente se le ordenó
comparecencia con restricciones y el
pago de una pequeña multa vamos ahora a
Brasil la Corte Suprema cientos de
órdenes de búsqueda de captura además de
órdenes de prisión contra Seguidores del
presidente Jair bolsonaro sospechosos de
organizar lo que calificó como actos
antidemocráticos se trata del bloqueo de
carreteras y llamados a un golpe de
estado que se dieron luego de que el ex
mandatario Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
ganará las elecciones el pasado mes de
octubre desde río deja negro nuestra
corresponsal Valeria sacone con los
detalles
la Policía Federal de flagrado hoy una
macrooperación contra Seguidores del
presidente Jair bolsonaro por haber
financiado y organizado actos definidos
antidemocráticos Como cortar carreteras
en todo el país desde hace semanas o
hacer campamentos frente a los cuarteles
militares de las principales ciudades de
Brasil esto acontece en nueve de los 27
estados federados de Brasil después de
que la Corte Suprema emitiese más de 100
órdenes de búsqueda y capturas y también
cuatro de prisión recordamos que de
diciembre el día en que Luis y naceliba
recibió el diploma de presidente en
Brasilia la capital hubo disturbios que
se saldaron con varios autobuses y
coches quemados y también con un intento
de invadir la sede de la Policía Federal
Por cierto Lula ha prometido que después
de la impidura el 1 de enero acabará con
esas protestas y con los campamentos
frente a los cuarteles también hay que
Resaltar que la operación se realiza un
día después de que el Tribunal Superior
electoral abriese una investigación
contra Yari bolsonaro dos de sus hijos
el diputado Eduardo y el senador Flavio
y el candidato a la vicepresidencia
Walter braganetto por supuestamente
apoyar esos actos antidemocráticos
ahora pasamos a Honduras el gobierno del
país centroamericano y la ONU sellaron
un acuerdo para establecer la comisión
internacional contra la corrupción e
impunidad un organismo que según la
presidenta Xiomara Castro será
independiente y justo y se encargará de
investigar las redes de corrupción
público privadas de alto impacto que han
saqueado al país la ampliación de esta
noticia desde Tegucigalpa con nuestra
corresponsal Kenia Torres
la presidenta de Honduras
Xiomara Castro firmó el protocolo para
sellar la instalación de una misión
internacional de lucha contra la
corrupción y la impunidad en Honduras en
la sede de las Naciones Unidas la
mandataria informó a través de su cuenta
oficial de Twitter y abro comillas junto
al secretario general de las Naciones
Unidas instalaremos una Sisi
independiente y justa Asimismo la
mandataria dijo que han logrado acuerdos
para la selección de expertos que
trabajarán y que además investigarán las
redes de corrupción públicos y privadas
de alto impacto que según la mandataria
han saqueado el país la traída de la
Sisi a Honduras fue una de las promesas
de campaña más importantes de la
presidenta Castro quien se comprometió a
luchar frontalmente contra la corrupción
anteriormente existía en el país
también una misión internacional de
lucha contra la corrupción la Maxi sin
embargo en enero del 2020 y gracias a
que el expresidente Juan Orlando
Hernández se negó a extender este
convenio con la oea esta organización
tuvo que marcharse del país sin embargo
sus investigaciones fueron de alto
impacto ya que gracias a ellas muchos
diputados políticos y empresarios fueron
llevados a la justicia hondureña
repasamos otras noticias de la región en
France 24 en Argentina los precios al
consumidor subieron en noviembre
92,4% en términos interanuales es decir
el acumulado de los últimos 12 meses el
departamento de estadísticas destacó que
sin embargo la inflación del 4,9% frente
a octubre representó el aumento mensual
más corto desde febrero y muy por debajo
de lo que esperaban los analistas
el salario mínimo en Colombia subirá 16%
en 2023 un nivel de aumento que no se
veía desde hace más de dos décadas según
el acuerdo al que llegaron este jueves
el gobierno las centrales obreras y los
gremios empresariales el sueldo mínimo
mensual será de un millón 160 mil pesos
colombianos un poco más de 240 dólares
al cambio de hoy por segundo año
consecutivo el alza salarial está varios
puntos porcentuales por encima de la
inflación que hasta noviembre era del
12,53%
El Banco Central de México subió su tasa
de interés en medio punto porcentual
hasta el 10,5% un nivel nunca visto en
su historia se trata del décimo tercer
incremento consecutivo en un intento de
controlar la inflación que ronda el 8% y
que es la más alta en dos décadas
y Avanza en Canadá la conferencia de la
ONU sobre biodiversidad en la que
ministros de 196 países negocian un
acuerdo global que puede detener el
deterioro de los ecosistemas de aquí a
2023 sin embargo el tiempo corre y
algunos puntos impiden que haya consenso
entre las partes desde Montreal en
nuestra corresponsal Carolina Villa
mediana con los detalles
este jueves comenzó en el Palacio de
congresos de Montreal el segmento de
alto nivel la etapa final y decisiva de
la cop 15 la Cumbre de las Naciones
Unidas para la biodiversidad ministros
de ambiente de 196 partes intentan
ponerse de acuerdo en los temas
políticos relacionados con la aprobación
de un marco global para detener el
deterioro de los ecosistemas del planeta
de aquí a 2030 el ministro de ambiente
chino quien también preside destacó
Indicó que ya hay 23 puntos en los que
las partes han logrado un consenso y
quedan otras ocho decisiones por ser
tomadas en las próximas horas sin
embargo hay varios puntos en los cuales
no se ha logrado un acuerdo y el tiempo
apremia algunos de estos puntos en los
que ha habido dificultad para alcanzar
el consenso tienen que ver con las
finanzas Donde ha aparecido la polémica
entre los países más pobres los países
en vías de desarrollo que concentran la
mayor parte de los ecosistemas del
planeta y los países más ricos países
desarrollados que tendrían la mayor
parte de los recursos para hacer avanzar
esta agenda otro de los puntos difíciles
ha tenido que ver con los sistemas
digitales de información genética es por
esto que el ministro ambiente chino ha
buscado la colaboración de varios de sus
pares para hacer avanzar las
negociaciones sobre estos puntos en
concreto nos referimos a los ministros
de ambiente de Canadá Alemania chile
Ruanda Egipto y Noruega y finalizamos en
Estados Unidos la oficina de archivos
nacionales publicó más de 13.000
documentos relacionados con el asesinato
del expresidente John F Kennedy en 1963
luego de que el presidente Joe biden
ordenará desclasificarlos Aunque su
publicación no cambiará la conclusión de
los investigadores si ayudará a que los
historiadores se centren en los eventos
relacionados con el asesinato que se ha
promovido como una teoría de
Conspiración en varios libros películas
y programas de televisión
hasta aquí este informativo Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]